j'étais même venu vous voir en concert
et très longtemps avec ma maman on était
fan absolu vous aviez une robe
magnifique
sur scène c'est un truc de fou
c'était incroyable
c'est ce soir vous venez nous voir parce
que vous avez sorti chez Columbia nouvel
album merci pour le regard donc c'est
pas un titre destiné à Benjamin Castaldi
bien entendu
c'est sûr que c'est pas pour vous
regarder le clip d'un des plus beaux
titres de l'album les vents contraires
sens
[Musique]
je pense à toi
joue l'album de Sylvie merci pour le
regard et j'adore c'est très moderne
et c'est
[Musique]
toujours la même chose
et j'ai envie de faire différemment
c'est toujours en fonction de
ce
que j'ai
fait beaucoup de
d'avoir cette se contacte
ce côté confidentiel est intime que que
vous donne la possibilité
d'interpréter des chansons qui sont
comme des scènes de vie théâtrale que
que d'habitude je dirais ta confidence
comme toi je fais les animaux avec moi
qui ai fait vraiment pour
alors je dis les choses
c'est quand même un bonheur
et Sylvie Vartan
et
maintenant
un peu partout
en vrai aussi et donc j'ai grandi avec
le public parce que j'ai toujours aimé
justement sur ton tarte chocolat et
artiste que quand on a ce contact avec
les gens et ça devient physique ça
devient Organics on ressent les choses
chérie comment faire pour être
force d'intensité que c'est vrai que
c'est plus vite que vous avez fait
rester au top comme ça pendant 60 ans
mais oui c'est ça
tout le monde
[Musique]
aussi
j'aimais bien ça j'avais les petites
filles les mamans les grand-mère parce
qu'en fait j'étais pas quelqu'un
je sais pas je ne sais pas
incroyable et je faisais des choses
qui venait de mes rêves j'avais envie de
te faire rêver justement donc je pars
mais costume par les décors et comme
j'ai toujours eu envie de faire du
théâtre du cinéma j'ai toujours
privilégié le côté théâtral et
interprète plutôt que chanter vraiment
parce que je ne voyais pas de carrière
en fait je ne pensais pas ma ma vie car
hier je ne savais pas que j'allais
rester aussi
mon grand bonheur évidemment mais j'ai
toujours voulu faire des choses
différemment pour donner moi-même et
pour pour m'intéresser et pouvoir
redonner ça et c'est vrai que au fur à
mesure j'ai fait tellement de tourner
que je crois que nous avons fait des
tournées sans fin pendant des années et
des années des années et j'aime partir
en tournée j'aime aller en province je
connais la France par cœur et le monde
aussi d'ailleurs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est que votre lien n'a jamais été
public français et pourtant vous avez
été
[Rires]
et pourtant
merci vu ton maire de passer la merde